I wanna further the deep dive into the crunchy to crazy pipeline
and why the conspiracy theory is so dangerous
and why it depends on the mental illness of mothers
and how that ties into my fears about RFK's appointment
I'm coming from this not from a place of judgement
I'm coming from a place of experience
because there is a point in time
where I was heavily influenced by crunchy tendencies
I started a homeopathic remedy kit
I took colloidal silver I had Mullen garlic
I started preparing homemade everything down to
like elderberry gummies
and I got an air popper
because microwave popcorn was full of cancerous carcinogens
tried to import as many things as I could
because I had read way too much about the industrialized farming
and the industrialized food industry here in the United States
they've always said that there is a good point
there is a spectrum
to being concerned and proactive about what you put in your body
and obviously this sort of specialized diet conversation
does not go for people who have food sensitivities
or food intolerances or require a specialized diet
what I'm talking about is that there are those of us
who get so hooked in the anxiety of it
that it goes to an unhealthy place
and how I recognize that I was an unhealthy place
could potentially help somebody
if you're on that path because I developed what is called orthorexia
and that is when you are so concerned
about unsafe or eating only clean foods
that it becomes an obsession
it becomes a level of mental illness
and it becomes really really unhealthy
so how to tell if you're in a unhealthy eating place
as far as your crunchy tendencies
one you cannot socialize or go over to other people's houses to eat
cause you're worried about there not being any safe foods for you to eat
if you don't think your kid can go to a kid's birthday
because they may or may not have pizza and a cupcake at that birthday
and that that would cause too much harm for your child
if you believe any medical intervention
is going to negatively impact the health and safety of your child
those are top three
because people like RFK and people who are in this country community
people selling um dotera
people selling the essential oil things
are benefiting and capitalizing on your fear
and that fear can go from a normal place that keeps you safe and healthy
and making informed choices
to an unsafe place
that completely impacts not only how you view the medical community
our food system our government
and then ultimately other groups of people
cause it depends on fear it depends on mental illness
and it depends on the ability to manipulate your feelings
about your own personal safety
and mothers
especially mothers experiencing postpartum anxiety and postpartum OCD
like I was are especially
especially susceptible to this
because you're watching this crunchy motherhood community rally around RFK
like he is the answer to all of the corruption within our food system
and I'm very well versed in our food system
I'm a trained chef and I have hyper fixated on like
Michael Poland's books and the industrialized food system
so I know there are negatives that need to be addressed
he is also talking negatively about people who are on ADHD medications or um
antidepressants and and mood disorder medication
don't think that this is also not gonna spill over to birth control
because the crunchy motherhood community
also speaks really negatively about birth control
and yes there are side effects to birth control
there is nothing you participate in
there is not one choice that you make
where you are not weighing the pros and cons
the pros of birth control for women as a whole outweigh the cons at the moment
does that mean we should be putting more research into it
putting more money into it
making it a safer product
researching women's health at a more um
aggressive level yes
but taking away a safety net for women because you think it's too toxic
is not the answer
you cannot take away a safety net without something else in place
I feel the same way about our food system
we have an industrialized food system
that is made to feed a large majority of people
if you have money and you have access
you can get better ingredients
you can grow your own food
you can support local farms
people who do not have the ability time
money or access to local small farms require the industrialized food system
kids who are getting free school lunches
communities that are food deserts uh
they require cheap food so
if we are not going to first
make sure that all of our communities have access to healthily grown
sustainably grown and cheap
inexpensive Whole Foods you can't take away or highly regulated system
that is currently keeping people from starving
because guess what
people would rather be fed low quality food than not be fed at all
I feel exactly the same about vaccines
there are people who want to have the option to put their kids in public school
without vaccinations there's people who are saying oh
it's my personal responsibility
it is not there are negatives to taking vaccines
there are positive to taking vaccines
the positives as a community system
far outweigh the potential
negligible percentage of people who have an adverse reaction
making you scared of something that is in your best benefit to do and use
and depend on is manipulation
things like antibiotics things like bleach and household cleaners
things like fast food even solved a problem that existed
can these things be better
yes but be very careful that you are not being manipulated by your fear
and your anxieties and your mental illness into a place where you are now
going to distrust everything
every modern convenience and modern invention that has been created
that has solved the the death or the suffering of millions of people over time
because that's not in your best interest
and they're depending on it